Those big sunglasses can't hide that the actress
who plays Jeffrey Dahmer's mother in Netflix's
"Monster" is probably familiar to lots of viewers.
Here's where you've likely seen her before.
Netflix's new true-crime series "Dahmer
– Monster: The Jeffrey Dahmer Story" once
again seeks to adapt the true story of the
infamous serial killer for the screen. The
series was co-created by Ryan Murphy and Ian
Brennan, the minds behind series including
"American Crime Story," "American Horror
Story," and "Scream Queens." Evan Peters,
who fans may identify as Quicksilver from
the X-Men franchise, stars as Dahmer.
Murphy has stressed the importance of centering
Dahmer's victims and their families, as well as
the institutional racism and ineptitude that
allowed Dahmer to keep killing for as long as
he did. The series goes back into Dahmer's high
school years and features a crop of stars as the
disturbed youngster's guardians, who fail to
understand what the young man would become.
Richard Jenkins stars as Dahmer's father, Lionel,
and Molly Ringwald plays his stepmother, Shari.
His mother, Joyce, is played by Penelope
Ann Miller, whose first big roles were in
the theater. Her Broadway career began
in a 1985 production of "Biloxi Blues."
She reprised the role in the 1988 film
adaptation alongside Matthew Broderick,
and she earned a Tony nomination for
the 1989 Broadway revival of "Our Town."
Big film roles followed suit, and Miller
starred in a number of family-friendly
flicks in the late '80s. In 1987, she co-starred
in "Adventures in Babysitting" as Chris' frenzied
friend Brenda. In 2017, on the movie's
30th anniversary, she reminisced to ET,
"That was the beginning. That
was the beginning of my career."
The next year, she appeared in "Big Top Pee-wee"
as Pee-wee Herman's fiancée, Winnie Johnson.
Miller kicked off the 1990s by starring
alongside two gangster-movie legends. The
L.A. native put on a thick New York accent
to play Marlon Brando's daughter in "The
Freshman," a crime comedy that had her once
again sharing scenes with Matthew Broderick.
"I don't know who. They. It was in
the United States, is my point."
She also co-starred with Robert De
Niro in the considerably more dramatic
film "Awakenings." Based on neurologist
Oliver Sacks' memoir of the same name,
the film stars Robin Williams as a doctor and
De Niro as an encephalitis patient. Miller
plays another patient's daughter, who starts a
romantic relationship with De Niro's character.
Brando and De Niro weren't the only big stars who
Miller rubbed shoulders with in 1990. That year,
she also appeared alongside Arnold
Schwarzenegger in "Kindergarten Cop."
In 1993, Miller worked with yet another
"Godfather" star, Al Pacino, in 1993's "Carlito's
Way." Directed by Brian de Palma, the film follows
a New York criminal struggling to leave behind
his lawbreaking ways. For her role as Carlito's
girlfriend, Gail, Miller earned a Golden Globe
nomination for Best Actress. Miller was initially
dubious about the character, who is a stripper.
But ultimately, it was too good an opportunity
to pass up. She told The Baltimore Sun,
"I figured I could meet with Pacino at least,
and he could see my work. I could establish a
relationship with him and Brian DePalma.
But I realized that this was a great,
meaty role and that the stripping
was such a very small part of it."
Miller then went on to star in the 1997 creature
feature "The Relic." After that, she returned
to Broadway and made TV appearances in series
including "The Closer" and "Desperate Housewives."
In 2011, she had a supporting role in
"The Artist." The nostalgic throwback
to silent-film-era Hollywood
cleaned up during awards season,
winning three Golden Globe Awards and five
Academy Awards, including Best Picture.
In the film, Miller plays Doris,
the embattled wife of silent film
star George Valentin. Of the challenges
of silent acting, Miller told MakingOf,
"I think the daunting task is to
be believable and authentic to the
period. [...] You don't want to overdo it and
seem like you're over-acting or being gimmicky."
Miller was perhaps the only "Artist" cast member
to have any sort of silent acting experience. She
played silent film actress Edna Purviance in
1992's "Chaplin" alongside Robert Downey Jr.